welcome to a special father's day
edition of the into the impossible
podcast with yours truly professor brian
keating
and it is no stretch of the imagination
to say i wouldn't be a professor without
today's guest
peter was my phd advisor and as much as
you can say in academia he is basically
like my
academic father and we talk about our
influences his phd advisor the late
great david wilkinson
after whom the uh nasa satellite called
the wmap satellite was named
he had a tremendous career also
connected to
the initial discovery of the cosmic
microwave background famous being told
by
one of his colleagues bob dickey at
princeton as you'll hear
boys we've been scooped by penzias and
wilson
but peter fulfills that role as we say
in the
russian language the word for scientists
translates to someone who was taught
and to me that implicates the scientist
as having a duty and obligation
morally or otherwise to teach and to
teach people
but not only in the laboratory teach
them the schrodinger equation
perturbation equations in
in quantum mechanics or in general
relativity or in my case how to build a
microwave radiometer
and look for the polarization of the
microwave background but also
in life lessons some of my greatest
mentors in life
were scientists scientists such as peter
such as andrew lang the late great
andrew lang that i write about
in losing the nobel prize and
these men and women that advise students
have a solemn duty
but also we become part of each other's
lives so peter is in my life nearly 30
years after i met him as a bumbling
fumbling graduate student at brown
university
now he's at wisconsin he still makes
time every time i need something from
him or
i want to talk to him and this is really
just a highlight and to have it is my
academic father literally is such a
treat so i hope you'll enjoy this uh
this
video it's a little bit different
talking about personalities talking
about
influences talking about the biggest
picture topics
in science but not only within the
laboratory also outside of it
so it's a little bit different i hope
you'll enjoy it and let me know in the
comments what you think about it should
we do
more conversations with scientists about
life outside the scientific laboratory
or
research setting uh or would you like to
hear more of the
videos that we've done lately uh deep
dives into
things like loop quantum gravity into
black hole physics and otherwise
so for now please do subscribe and also
sit back and enjoy this ride into the
impossible with my academic father
professor peter timby of the university
of wisconsin
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
today we are speaking with
um a man who more than almost any other
person
has taken me to the heights or the
depths
it's not clear if he gets credit or if
he gets blame it's professor peter timby
of the university of wisconsin at
madison
who is my phd advisor and who has been a
good friend
a loving mentor and really
you know one of the guides on how to be
a good scientist that i've
attempted and obviously failed because
i'm not as good an advisor as he is
anyway peter how are you today it's
still march and so i assume that the
thaws will set in any you know month now
any quarter now how is it out in the
middle of the west yes so hello brian
it's great to see you
again we're doing fine here so you know
even though it's not san diego
uh we have uh winter is over so we've
got
the uh the lakes are still
frozen though that'll continue for some
months but
um snow is gone and uh birds are out so
yes so you you know it's been a while
since you've been in wisconsin and
uh and spent your own days um
at the observatory and through the cold
winter and so forth um
but we're yeah we've we've passed into a
new phase before the bugs have come
yeah i was there probably 10 years ago
maybe uh i'll
come back but i i've recently thought
out from that visit
which was you know the coldest july 4th
ever no no
i was there in the fall and it actually
was so tempting you know my wife and i
only had one kid back then
and they were like why didn't you like
it here and i was like well
i loved you know the people i loved the
university
but this thing called winter it would
usually kick in around you know
september and usually thaw by june and
it was the greatest you know kind of
three month period of that you could
ask for but actually it is a lovely
place the university is phenomenal it is
top-notch
and uh and i thought we'd kind of like
maybe review some of the past history
but
but also i want to talk to you about
pedagogy because when
i was in under your tutelage the thing
that i always learned is that you would
give me
a lot of freedom and one and you'd make
a lot of connections for me and
i kind of uh wanted to obviously express
gratitude for that
but also to kind of ask you because i
never really knew it
um you know whether that was intentional
or whether it's like with kids you could
never know what you're going to get
because you introduced me to
somebody named alex polmarev who is a
titanic figure in theoretical cosmology
and
came up with a lot of stuff we do
studying b mode polarization etc
looking for waves of gravity imprinted
on the cosmic microwave background
and uh and you let me work with him and
he was sort of a
surrogate advisor in a sense or an
additional supplemental advisor rather
uh and he's a theorist and you're an
experimentalist um was that part of your
plan or was that just the way that
things worked out is that is that
intentional that you gave me this extra
kind of care
you know an attention that i surely did
not deserve
yeah well i think you're actually giving
me a little bit too much credit because
um so alex came for a visit to
uh to brown to uh to um
for extended time to talk to robert
brandenburger
uh and um so i think it was during that
visit
that um you know all of us connected
and i think i think though where i
probably gave you a lot more slack than
many advisors would would do
is i a i i
i think for your first i don't know half
a year working on the project with me
you were working
mostly with him right so the idea was
weird you um
actually you and he were leading a paper
about um this experiment to look at
um cmb polarization and so just laying
out some some fundamentals about how
how that ex experiment might work what
you know
whether would be feasible um
and so yeah i think i think you
basically um
were uh working almost entirely with him
for
quite a while before you actually got
your hands dirty building stuff
and doing doing what i really needed and
wanted you to do
so it was um for me it was great though
because
um alex um you know of course a world
expert on these kinds of things
uh provided a theoretical background
that i you know i couldn't do
so um
i yeah so so it was it was um
i think so you're not giving yourself
enough credit because you really
took a very mature approach to dealing
with this
uh authority to figure and and uh you
know
getting what you you know learning what
you could from him
um which is you know consistent with
what you've done
uh i think for with um lots of uh um
knowledgeable people you know uh so
you've you've kept in touch with me
uh over the years and and i know you
have with lots of people in the field so
you know
i think um uh
yeah so so it's but but i i it is true i
do
i was really happy to see you um
sort of taking the initiative and and
taking you know doing things
independently
um and then of course i continued right
so i think i cut you
enough rope to hang yourself with on
your thesis
itself um but that was you know that
actually connects to
the way i was trained by um dave
wilkinson when i was a grad student
so i think i was channeling some of the
uh techniques that he used in advising
difficult people like myself
not as difficult as you but it turns out
at least some of those techniques
and mentoring yeah worked uh worked well
i think
yeah i've been known to win the nobel
prize in obnoxiousness
uh and i wanted to say one thing that
alex palmerev our russian
colleague that we spoke about earlier
that he
communicated to me early on in our
engagement together
was that in russian the word scientist
means uh someone who was taught in other
words it's it's basically connotes
that you are educated but that you could
not be a scientist if you weren't
you know mentored and educated and for
me that also means that you have this
obligation to become a teacher once
you're a scientist and
i've gone off on rants lately about you
know how basically we should be forced
and strapped into
you know communication uh you know
thunder domes where we are forced to
communicate what we do because the
taxpayers pay so much for us to do this
fun stuff that we'd probably do for free
in a lot of cases i mean i always was
having fun
in lab uh this and you know and despite
the pecuniary you know
salary that you paid me at the time
which i think was
four digits you know talk about i i'm
not that's standardized it wasn't
peter's fault that i was paid so low
um uh but uh but then i started thinking
you know like
yeah you were connected to david
wilkinson i met him a couple times
thanks to you
um and then i have a student darcy baron
who's a professor at the university of
new mexico now
and then now she has a student kayla
mitchell who's a student at the
university
and they're writing papers about
microwave radiometers
and i'm thinking back how you know this
connects through to you and to
david wilkinson and to robert dickey in
this huge line
and we'll show in the in the b-roll
footage as the
wonks will say you know we'll show our
genealogy our phd genealogy
which goes through me and through you
goes all the way back to a guy by the
name of leibniz
but not the famous leibniz another
leibniz i believe it was
and uh and and this is uh you know an
amazing person
who had uh a wife and his wife's name
her maiden name was schmuck
and i always thought that was
appropriate you know at least for me uh
but but let's let's take a step through
how we came our origin story together so
we were at brown
you were a professor a young assistant
professor at brown
i was a a neophyte a a novice i'd
come into graduate school thinking i
might do theoretical physics or
condensed matter of fizz i didn't know
what the heck i was doing and uh i
i did some you know some research with
some of the professors there
and i asked around you know their
students and you know and and one of
them had
had a white beard and i remember being
very intimidated by this student who had
yet to graduate in his mid-50s or
something
i won't say who his advisor is his
advisor is no longer with us but
but anyway and i start you know who are
the cool new professors the young
the young upstarts that uh will be
hungry and will
it will kind of uh be a good steward
regardless of what they studied and it
was your name
and professor valas uh jim vallis who's
i know is a good friend of yours
and you know there are a few and that
was basically it and i said cosmology i
was always interested in astronomy
but um but one thing that really
appealed to me is that you were doing
stuff that was new
and in retrospect that was really risky
and i'm wondering you know
how did you balance the risks to your
career and like obviously you wanted to
get tenure you were an assistant you'd
only been there for a couple years what
year did you start at brown again
uh 1990 1990 yeah so this was 93
late 1993 when i showed up and there we
already had a couple of students
uh some of whom are faculty grant grant
wilson and others nowadays
so you've got many offspring as is one
lesson i want to communicate to you an
offspring of offspring that are now
graduate students it's amazing
uh but were you scared i mean was it a
risky thing was it not risky for you to
take on this huge new project
studying something this is you know be
right after kobe had detected
an isotropy in the cmb but nobody
thought some said it was impossible
to detect the fluctuations and
polarization of the cme
were you scared um
no i wasn't and actually you know it's
interesting how i
i remember actually deciding that this
was a really good project to do
because i was i was actually at a
meeting
um probably in 1992 or something
at princeton and i was looking at the
the direction the field was going so
this is a you know meeting about
microwave background measurements and at
that time it was you know
temperature anisotropy was what
everybody was doing
and there was a talk that wilkinson gave
about uh you know what was the next what
was the next step
and so he put up a
slide of a a um
you know sort of his view of what a
satellite mission would look like
basically this was the first
anybody um first time i had seen
somebody talking about something
uh to follow kobe the kobe satellite
and this was maybe the first time
he had what became the wmap experiment
um which you know went on to do amazing
things but it was at that meeting i was
thinking
well you know here i am in this room
with um
even at that time in a you know was a
fairly compact field there were
um maybe a hundred people there
um so all you know people working on the
microwave background radiation
and thinking um how you know how am i
going to make an impact on a
on a you know field that's obviously
exploding
and uh but also where most of the energy
is going towards
um a few few uh ever
expanding uh experiments in one of them
of course the the wmap experiment
and so it seemed to me that i
you know it was going to be best for me
to try something a little bit different
right especially you know you know
because of tenure coming up
i only had a few you know you only have
a few years to to do something
and so you know to do something brand
new although risky would also
you know you know it'd be a lot of fun
for one thing and also
you know wouldn't have to figure out how
am i going to plug into an experiment
that's going to have a timeline that's
that's much longer than that
so so i was still you know i still
maintained involvement in um
ballooning experiments the uh the top
hat experiment and the uh what was
called the
m sam experiment the medium scale
anisotropy measurement
so these were looking for temperature
fluctuations
in the uh the cmb from balloons
but uh yeah the the polarization
experiment that became your thesis
was um really distinctive
and nobody else is doing something like
that at that time
and so um it was a way to
you know feel like i had some and my
group
could have some some breathing room so
that we weren't
plugged into some um very competitive
field which you know of course the field
remains extremely competitive
as you know and i think maybe a theme
for
for research projects that i've tried to
follow is is to
try to first try to see if there's some
angle i can work that might be a little
bit different something that
other people aren't trying sometimes
that's worked
um and sometimes uh not so good right
and
so um yeah so i i guess i wasn't i
wasn't really
too worried about this this seemed like
a just a really cool
cool thing to do yeah and even
i think it was prescient in a sense that
we were looking for the large angular
scale polarization of that microwave
background and
it's true the microwave background has
these three distinct properties it's
temperature
it's black body characteristic it's
spectrum it's an isotropy
and it's polarization and these features
you know to this very day are still
relatively unexplored and the fact that
this
the cousin microwave background remains
our oldest
you know fossil relic of the of the
infant universe
uh will uh will continue for quite some
time obviously with the simon's
observatory and the simon's array and
bicep array and all these
uh incarnations of of large angular and
uh
polarization measurements means that
we're not done yet and ever
i remember coming into the field and
meeting with the past guest on the show
uh paul steinhardt uh who you had
brought he was at the time at
upenn and you had brought him in to give
a colloquium and
basically saying we're never going to
detect this you know b mode polarization
or
at that time and he had worked on the
polarization of the microwave background
uh from gravitational waves and saying
it's impossible and maybe it is
impossible
and maybe that's uh why we have the name
of this podcast
into the impossible because we are not
scared to challenge ourselves
um i want to ask you about your
recollections of david wilkinson
and of of dickie above dickie in any way
that you
care to to kind of comment on them
you're kind of this
vital uh stepping you know stone at
least
in my mind and people that you know uh
and have
interacted with uh but you're also you
know obviously a font of wisdom on your
own
so how did they inform your
thought process as a scientist as a
mentor he already mentioned a little bit
of
of kind of the freedom that david gave
you but uh
but how did they augment the kind of
nascent ability that you had as an
educator and as a scientist
how do they you know how did they
develop how help your career develop in
the way that it did
yeah um well so first of all um yeah so
dave wilkinson you know i worked with
him really closely
um and not so much with dicky so dicky
was around
um and uh you know significant
presence at princeton uh um you know
while i was in graduate school um but
most of my interaction with
was with dave um but they were you know
they were both
really uh supportive
and um uh you know
i guess you know they they there was
sort of a
dual role that they played one was to
set a really good example
i mean this is for both of them really
good example of what a great scientist
could
was like but um
but they were also really encouraging uh
in the sense of
yeah just helping young people like
myself and
um it you know it
i remember you know getting to graduate
school thinking
and you know even when i finish graduate
school thinking there's
there's no way i'm going to be like
these people and and realize you know i
realized very early on that there's
you know comparing myself to to
almost anybody um
princeton in those days was you know not
not a helpful
healthy thing to do but um wilkinson in
particular was just
really really supportive as uh you know
as
as we were working together on my thesis
project which was an
early attempt to measure the
temperature fluctuations in the
microwave background radiation
um and so yeah so we were talking before
about
my pedagogical style trying to to keep
you in line as a graduate student um
so dave was um you know he did he gave
me
also lots of slack right so i would
you know i part of it was you know i did
i had a pretty clear idea what i wanted
to do on a
thesis and and he let me run with that
which was really good
um but he would um and he would drop by
the lab which was right next to the
coffee machine
strategically placed there and he would
just sort of wander in
you know hand in pocket and the other
hand in the on the coffee mug and uh
in the most gentle way try to find out
what i was doing
and then um you know without pressuring
me
um without my even
realizing it he was just checking out
that i was on the right track
i don't remember him ever saying
you know you're going about this all
wrong there were times when i came away
from the conversation and realized that
was really what he was trying to say but
he was just very diplomatic
and um and so
yeah i don't know if i was yeah i'm
pretty sure i was equally diplomatic
with with
with you brian um but he
yeah so he he could simultaneously uh
you know provide this inspiration that
um
in my career but also
um make it clear that you know just
provide a supportive environment where i
could i could um
i could make my own stakes and and
mistakes and and grow
without the a heavy hand which i know
you know other advisors have different
techniques and um
for me this worked really well do you
think some of that was because he was
involved in so many projects from you
know kind of
wrapping up kobe when you were you
started there what in
mid 80s or uh when he was actually uh
79 he started my first okay first year
on the job so
kobe was really in the middle of its
development you know this is like a
15-year program and um
yeah he was pretty busy um he was
um i could you know i think i think in a
way he was
you know just he was very careful with
his time so
he you know he didn't over schedule his
you know meetings with me and
with anybody else as far as i could tell
but he did have a lawn at his plate with
the kobe thing coming along and then he
was running this big uh the big gravity
group there princeton
after uh this is you know in the years
that dickie was retiring and stepping
down from that
that role so he didn't have a lot of
time
um he was also though very
good i learned something else from him
which i've tried to imitate and that is
very good at trying to carve out what he
needed he
you know he was he's a very gentle
fellow but he
you know there was like a he's sort of a
a fist inside of a glove right he
he he was a very had a very strong
sense of himself but on the outwardly
just being a really wonderful person to
to uh
to deal with uh but he would he would
reserve
friday afternoons for his own work
so he had a toolbox in the lab that had
a skull and crossbones on it nobody was
to go into this toolbox and friday
afternoons he would be at a drafting
table or
putting together uh stuff from the lab
but this is for
a balloon experiment he was building to
measure the absolute temperature of the
microwave background radiation
sort of a um sort of in a way a
follow-on to the original experiment
he'd done in the 60s too
that actually discover the microwave
background right
and so he you know he didn't do things
that he didn't want to do
and so i i could tell you know the time
he spent with me
um in the lab was you know he really
wanted to be there he enjoyed you know
he enjoyed uh
you know talking about new ideas
and he you know he just liked being a
mentor i think that's maybe the bottom
line
yeah and you mentioned obviously the you
know the connection that he had
i always you know from afar again i only
met him a couple times
but i always knew from afar uh that he
uh was really fascinating i mean he
could do anything you know
i think his thesis was on like the muon
and anomalous magnetic moments or
something
while he was at u michigan uh but uh but
really his his one true muse was the
cosmic microwave background
and maybe even you know within that the
the essence of his fascination with it
was
measuring it detecting it for the first
time whether it be its spectrum
uh or its uh or its anisotropy pattern
or eventually its polarization
he didn't live to see that uh
unfortunately but
um but i wonder you know you arrived
there in 1979 that was a year after
penzias and wilson won the nobel prize
uh for the discovery of the kazakh
microwave background made
serendipitously
uh not far from where you were at uh you
know just a year later
or a couple decades later but in
holmendel new jersey where i've been
and i wonder you know did he did he ever
talk about that or was it like you know
they
they say for old you know military
veterans from you know the
spanish-american
they don't want to talk about it you
know what happened to them he was
famously
you know com the the story that i relate
in losing the nobel prize
uh where you're prominently featured in
six of the 13 chapters
uh was you know we were scooped boys
we've been scooped as dicky's famous uh
alleged
commentary when he heard from a third
party uh
that that this measurement had been made
at bell labs they didn't really know how
to interpret it
uh and you know could dicky give this
interpretation and lo and behold was
related to what
uh he and roll and and uh david
um peoples were working on so did he
ever talk about it or was it like
no don't talk to david about that that's
a sore point
um you know so while i was there no i
don't remember him talking about it
um but i do remember you know after
coming
to coming here to wisconsin um
many years later um
he he so i had him come out and give a
colloquium and
you know i talked about um you know this
is in the early days of
of uh the wmap satellite i guess
you know pre-flight and you know was
talking about the design of it
and uh in what the science was all about
but he also uh he took um you know he
spent a whole day here and he spent
um a lunch time uh with us
talking about um
the story uh so he's you know he's he
said he volunteered he said you know i
uh would you like me to um talk about
the
the discovery of the the background
radiation well yeah i said sure
so so uh so i you know got the group
together as a for lunch
and um there were you know a bunch of
undergrads grad students
and um and you know he had a sort of
um an outline uh he had a you know a
single page
of uh showing the um you know from the
earliest days when the first
earliest concept of that their first
suggestions that
maybe there is would be a microwave
background
worth looking for that is a you know
some relic radiation from the big bang
um from the this is a calculation done
by
gamov and and others in the in the 40s
which um was
you know the calculation was published
but basically forgotten
by dickey and not known by wilkinson and
the others
uh in the 60s but he so he had this
whole process of how
um through various miscommunications or
missed
you know missed opportunities the um
discovery in the 60s was um
really a surprise while in retrospect
[Music]
you know the lots of reasons that we we
should have known or
or dickie in particular should have
known
in fact dickey himself had made a
measurement
uh of the mic of the background
back in the in the 40s it was a upper
limit
but it was um you know the first
measurement and but he had basically
forgotten that he'd done that
uh himself so anyway so so um
you know when he was telling the story
it was um
you know there was no i had didn't get
any sense that
he was upset about this you know having
missed this you know i think he just saw
this as
part of the big picture of how science
works
yeah it certainly never came across as
bitter
uh unlike me or anything like that
uh and i wonder what was their
relationship like
uh between dickie and wilkinson
obviously
he cast a long shadow um and he lived
you know quite a long time i mean he did
pass away and i think and while i was
still at wisconsin maybe 97
98 something like that and um you know i
remember you
and you know talking about it it was a
sad day but um what was dickey's
influence like on you personally but
also on
you know kind of the field as a whole of
both gravity research he was kind of
this
renaissance man was he not that could do
theory that could do experiment and yet
we don't hear very much about him
compared to a fineman
or you know one of these modern
physicists that you hear so much about
uh hawking and so forth but he to me was
a very very special and unique scientist
can you talk about
what your recollections are of him and
what was his relationship like with
david
yeah um yeah so they
they you know of course dickie was the
senior guy there and had brought on
had brought on dave and also jim peebles
um uh you know he
he was just you know just sort of
beyond comparison right i used to think
sometimes you know in some discussions
with dave that you know
maybe i had one up on him you know he
didn't understand something
and this is because i'd been you know i
was working on this experiment you know
night and day and you know
this is something he just stepped in and
now and then to look at
um but um
but dickie you know there's just he was
just
you know it's just yeah he's
he was just just from another realm
right the fact that he could do
experiments
and theory you know one person who could
do that
i don't i you know i've never met
anybody like that um
since then or before then he was just
really remarkable
i i do i do remember actually you know
in my first
it was my first year um in grad school
we had this journal club
uh you know we'd meet once a week and
people
would give presentations and there would
be a half hour for a
grad student and a half hour for one of
the faculty to do one
i was the organizer one year and so you
know this just meant
making sure that we had a schedule and
so just before one of the meetings i
um you know i saw that you know dickie
was on the the schedule and so i
went to his office just to make sure
that you know he's so you know he's
retired at this point he didn't you know
didn't have to
come to these meetings but i just wanted
to check and make sure he remembered he
was talking
and so and i think i was also talking
that day in the graduate student spot
and i'd been preparing and reading some
paper and trying to prepare my
presentation for you know for a week
and um you know almost a nervous wreck
over this and i went into his office and
he said
oh yes we uh yes uh we have journal club
today and
and uh he went over to his filing
cabinet
old-fashioned you know big gray metal
things and pull open the drawers
you know thousands of well hundreds of
papers that he'd written he said
which one do you think people would be
most interested in hearing about today
and i you know it's just
i you know at that time so this is you
know in the in the 90s he was
mostly talking about quantum mechanics
that was something that you know
it was a big theme for him throughout
his career um
yeah so he probably talked about quantum
mechanics but the fact that he had done
you know he had written the radiometer
equation done all these things
uh necessarily written the radiometer
paper that
um that we both know
and love yeah at the beginning of his
career all the way up through
gravitational wave um or gravitation
and you know a new theory of gravity uh
the cmb
um part of the invention of the laser
all these things is just just
mind-boggling so anyway so their their
connection was close but
you know they weren't working together
day to day um
really um wilkinson was sort of
over from as far as leading the group
right and when i uh think about that
paper of course we're talking about the
very first paper
that i was ever assigned as a graduate
student by my
soon to be graduate student thesis
advisor
and maybe for those that aren't familiar
i'll just say you know it's a it is a
very close relationship between
the mentored and the mentee or the
mentor or
however you want mento is it mento i
forget
protege and we had so many good times
and uh
you really made you know what was not an
easy situation graduate school is never
easy i don't care who you are and i
remember at one point kind of getting
disillusioned i
kind of reconnected with my father and i
was getting a little bit more torn
towards
learning about the fundamentals of
quantum mechanics maybe
or mathematics and and you said well
you're
you know it's not uh it's not a thesis
if you don't have at least one crisis
crisis of confidence and i remember you
saying you know you got to choose what
side you're on
no you never did that that would be
that's in the movie
but that never happened but uh but the
point is that you you know you were
uh extremely you're a gracious person um
you're
are incredibly uh skilled at mentoring
and and i think a lot of that
is you have this natural ability which
kind of
is on one hand it's very you know
exhilarating and
and appealing and then it's kind of
scary because i feel like
we're never taught how to be advisors
just like we're never taught how to be
parents
you know most of us have bad you know
kind of bad examples for parents so
i feel like we're you know the old
saying in psychology we're all victims
of victims
you know but but for me it's it's kind
of like learning on the job and
yesterday somebody asked me
who was a physicist he he became you
know now he's into like sustainable
energy or something like that but he he
was asking me like
um you know what is it about like this
relationship in graduate school
and i said something like um you know my
new kick is is that
science means knowledge in latin as you
know having studied latin cientia means
knowledge but it doesn't mean wisdom
and wisdom is something different it's
um
it's uh a different word in latin and
and
the point is that you know knowledge you
can get from
from wikipedia nowadays i mean back then
it didn't exist but
but uh but what you can't get even to
this day is wisdom and
and he was like well how do you apply
wisdom in your daily and i was like well
it's kind of similar to what happened to
me as a graduate student
i now am dealing with my graduate
students some of whom are considering
jobs and
and it's very unusual because the thing
you do once you know you get your first
postdoc
once well i mean for me i got fired for
my first post book so i actually had two
posts
two first postdocs if you will but we
won't get into that uh
but uh nevertheless you know from the
perspective of being an advisor
the you know wisdom is knowing not to
put a tomato
in a fruit salad which you know is a
fruit but
how do you actually apply that well i
think it's it's it's experience
and the problem is how do you get
experience as as you know i'm a pilot
i took you up one time and one time only
in a rental plane over
lake mendota in uh in madison and uh you
almost uh
lost your life and a very perilous
accident no no it wasn't an accident the
window popped open right
the window fell apart right the plane
was was
was collapsing right yeah you had to
like i wasn't freaking out
so for somebody with a fair heights as
you know and knew
knew at the time well uh
you know what could be worse right yeah
exactly but we made it we made it back
and you know
that you know on final approach to
landing i said i'm graduating next week
right
and and you know what choice did you not
know i would never do that actually you
know it was a wonderful experience you
did leave
brown in the middle of my third year
second year
uh to go to wisconsin obviously where
you are but i remember
you know you really made it uh like a
family and
i'm i'm genuinely appreciative of that
because i don't feel like i've been able
to replicate
what you did and and the way that you
you know kind of had a group
that felt like a family while you were
raising young kids and while your
wife is also a professor uh was dealing
you know with her career and your joint
career
and yet you always made us feel that it
was a family did you feel like
you know were you trained in that way it
doesn't sound like david was necessarily
like that i don't think of him like that
right
he wasn't like this you know kind of
grandfatherly i mean he was
later in life but how did you come about
that was it just who you are and
and if so what hope is there for other
people that aren't as naturally gifted
yeah so well yeah i mean i think it is
kind of you know just
you know what i was comfortable with i
mean it's again and not so different
from what
uh what dave did he um
[Music]
i remember he you know he would host the
gravity group picnic at his house
um um you know
where every summer and so you know that
was a
very welcoming thing um i yeah i
remember
um the first one of those i went to you
know i was really
really a nervous young a young young
grad student at thinking you know um do
i want to go
to this picnic where you know you've got
dicky and
and wilkinson and peebles and you know
these other famous people
and so i remember kind of scouting this
thing out from afar trying to you know
decide at the last minute whether i
should show
and um and he saw me right sort of
peeking in and he you know he you know
he came out and grabbed me and said you
know come on over and
and you know it he really was um
he really was a you know very friendly
very nurturing kind of person
and um so so
yeah i mean i i don't know if it was
conscious or not of
me or not but i i've i've
i've tried to recreate something like
that
um you know with my own own students
and um and you know i don't i guess it's
partly
who i am but also having a tremendous
role model
um you know i often think about you know
what
what would he have said in such a such a
situation and uh
yeah it's great to you know just have
those you know some very vivid memories
to
to uh to fall back on yeah so i want to
turn to the paper that you did assign me
again we're talking with my phd advisor
my friend my
mentor inspiration one time sparring
partner
in basketball um we won't talk about
those
defeats that were handed to you courtesy
of a much skinnier keating
uh but uh but i do want to sorry
that'll be for the rebuttal that you
present on 60 minutes
uh i want to talk about this paper
measurement of thermal radiation at
microwave frequencies i emailed it to
you but you don't necessarily have to
read it
as we're going now it's a paper you know
well you assigned it to me as a young
as a young incoming graduate student in
your group and by the way we used to
have
weekly meetings and i do replicate some
of the dna
from the timbe lab nowadays we have
weekly afternoon meetings where
we have a student present some cool new
paper even has nothing to do with what
we're doing
and i gave a bunch of those you know
irreverent
irrelevant and incomprehensible talks in
the timbi journal club
in addition uh to uh to presenting a
paper like this
which you had assigned and i now assign
this to my students and
i don't know i'm going to check with
darcy baron my uh my student is
professor in
new mexico and see if she assigns it to
her students and maybe we can get this
tradition going for
you know 17 more generations but um but
this paper
is really a very interesting one in the
history of physics because it
it was embargoed i think until after the
war
this is published in 1946 in the review
of scientific instruments now known as
rsi
uh and this was only the 17th year i
think that it was even in existence
and it was published after the war in
1946 and it's about
this uh outgrowth of the massachusetts
institute of technology and their
so-called radiation lab which was kind
of a counterpart right peter to the
manhattan project the more famous
of these great projects that the united
states military
slash academic physics community put
together to help win world war ii
um in this paper which was uh so it was
published when he was at
uh princeton he arrived i guess in
princeton it says there's a footnote now
at palmer physical laboratory princeton
university 1946
and but the work was done at mit and he
talks about
this really kind of delightful um
analogy that one can make and and the
laws between the laws of thermodynamics
on the one hand
and the laws of radio reception and
radar on the other hand
uh can you talk a little bit about your
recollections of this paper
um what made it so important to you how
did you find out about it i mean it's
not like
you know this was even common knowledge
back in the in the 70s and 80s when you
were a young graduate student how did
you find out about this paper
yeah so that's interesting uh so um i
i guess i at this point i can admit to a
case of
um scientific theft so
so i actually the my the first copy i
had of this paper
uh was stolen from wilkinson actually so
it's you know it's the same version that
uh you know you see
that you know printed out but it had his
name written in the upper right hand
corner
and uh so now my copy i mean i still
have that
wow and you know so it's now yellowed
and so forth so i'm
you know i'm sure this almost certain
that this is something that
that dave assigned to me or at least
recommended that i i looked at in the
early days
of you know learning about you know how
all this stuff worked
um you know how do you how do you make
how do you
measure uh the temperature microwave
background radiation and how do you how
do you
how do you yeah how do you understand it
as well and so this is a great
combination of experiment and a little
bit of theory
that uh you know just perfect right
you don't need to understand a lot
before you go into reading this and then
you can get
a lot out of it yeah so yeah the paper
i'm sure
this was this was required reading um
you know in grad school for people like
me
so uh looking over it what really
strikes me is
the uh very deep you know kind of
uh grounding that he's giving to people
thinking about this new technology it
would be like you know
blockchain for physicists i don't know
for people that are intelligent
enough to understand stuff but then it
was something that was embargoed i mean
it was really a matter of natural
secrecy at one point because even to
this day we can use this type of
technology
um to to you know make observations
about potential
um threats to the united states or you
know in the space force which
which i'm going to volunteer to join any
day now but but to monitor things in
space everything emits
black body radiation anything that's
made of matter will emit black body
radiation
and uh and and so anything can be
detected by some of the means
of detection that are outlined for the
first time really
in this in this paper and one thing that
came out of it is a very you know kind
of famous
uh laboratory technique that's used to
this very day and they can buy examples
of these
it's the so-called dickey switched a
radiometer phase sensitive detector
uh can you talk about what that was like
did dickie invent that
um what what is sort of the the uh
history of that particular invention
that's used in one form or another
in every experiment that we do uh but
also in commercial applications as well
yeah uh yeah as far as i know he did
invent this
certainly the the idea of phase
sensitive detection or sometimes called
lock-in detection
at least in the context of radiometry
which was of course what this paper was
about
um but i think you know just as a
general laboratory tool
um this um lock-in detection
um is something that
maybe had been used before but you know
you remember
dickie started a company in princeton
that made a commercial lock-in amplifier
so basically it's a scientific
instrument that
you know that labs would buy and they i
think we're the only
source for many years for getting one of
these things you know and still buy one
today but um
um and so they're very powerful tools so
but i think he
in fact invented this may have invented
the technique altogether both for
general purpose electronics as well as
radiometry so um
yeah so this you know and he describes
how this works in such a um
such a simple and logical way right so
that
i mean the illustrations in this paper
um
include um you know
sort of cartoons of of um
of radiation coming into instruments
that are
are beautifully shown and
um so yeah so so i think
to me this this is a great paper for new
people to look at just because of the
style
the writing is clearly trying to explain
how something works rather than
trying to show off um and so it's
very different from most of the papers
you find in the literature these days
yeah absolutely it uh to me was you know
it was a delight to read because it's
understandable it's comprehensible
it's uh evocative you can kind of
instantaneously get
what he's getting at he makes certain
approximations
and while i was reading it the first
time i was like why is he making these
and then later on do you i realize oh
he's just like really simplifying it
like he chooses this arbitrary noise
figure you know we'll get wonky for a
second he chooses it like to be nine
and then later we we i learned that you
know you add one to the noise figure and
that tells you something about the text
so later on to make the calculation be
uh simple to do in one's head
you know multiply 300 by 10 he had to
choose the noise factor to be
minus one or nine so it seems arbitrary
to me uh anyways it's very uh
it's very delightful to read it and just
kind of look at this magician
who's going through uh these these kind
of uh
relatively you know challenging things
to understand but making it such that we
can
understand it of course i love all the
little uh side notes that go back to
you know the the 1940s he talks about
the journal of the franklin institute
which
which doesn't exist anymore and then yes
yes those delightful
cartoons undoubtedly drawn by you know
some some
proto-graduate student or draftsman with
an o-u-g-h-t
um and then he thanks um who does he
think the writer is uh so he's right
i'm gratefully indebted to dr g e
ulenbach
who is of course very well known and
miss
m wang ms m wang so these are things
that
we don't do anymore but he talks about
the uh the you know kind of the the
parameters he gives an example he
describes
how one might make it and then he talks
about the most important aspect of all
which when i'm reading it you know with
the benefit of all the hindsight that i
have or whatever
uh insight i might have and i think he
talks about what's called calibration
and one of the most important aspects of
all the science that we do is
calibration
and in some sense i don't know what your
opinion is but i feel like penzies and
wilson
they were using the same radiometer that
was used by this guy edward ohm
i don't know much about him but he used
the same home deal antenna he had a very
similar receiver but what he didn't have
is the dickey switch
uh that would compare the temperature
coming in which we now know was
was dominated in some sense by the
cosmic background after
getting rid of what are known as
systematic errors but the other way to
compare it is
they were comparing liquid helium which
has a very well-known temperature
four degrees with the eventual
temperature of the microwave background
which is three degrees
and they were doing that many times per
second using this dickey switch
and i just thinking about it reading
this section on microwave calibration he
talks about well there could be
fluctuations that you misinterpret as
being attributable to
something coming into the antenna in the
case of the cmb from
from astrophysical sources potentially
and you might attribute that but it's
really a fluctuation in your instrument
and so you can freeze your instrument by
chopping between a calibration signal
and um and the signal coming in
from the astrophysical objects he talks
about measuring the sun and moon
and i'm just thinking you know like 20
years later he would have this
you know opportunity to measure the
microwave background and it was measured
using his technique and uh and he didn't
get the credit for that discovery
he you know he did he was he just had so
many ideas
that um i you know i don't know yeah he
didn't get the credit for it
um um he didn't get credit for a lot of
a lot of things and um you know it's a
little mysterious to me still why that
why that's true i mean people all have
recognized he's an amazing
guy yeah um
when i look at uh you know his career
again this file cabinet
effect where he just had so much stuff
in the in the in the file cabinet and
the rolodex in his mind
um yeah maybe it maybe i'm okay because
i don't have that many good ideas and
and therefore if i have one i'm just
gonna be obsessive and think about it
you know one thing i realized when i was
writing my book was that it wasn't
clear when they wrote their companion
paper so he famously got this call the
new york times is going to publish
this this result that the big bang had
been discovered at bell labs it was a
leak
to the new york times by um by some
radio astronomers and some people in the
public and
and bell labs had kind of tried to get
credit early
and so they ended up publishing a
companion paper right after pension
wilson which is like two or three times
longer than penzias and wilson's
paper in the astrophysical journal in
may i think 1965 or so
and in it the paper that dickey peebles
roll and wilkinson wrote they don't
mention the big bang at all
the big bang is not mentioned whatsoever
in this paper
and it's it's it's actually overshadowed
in any sense by
the notion that there might be a cyclic
universe going on and this was still
kind of in vogue in the 1960s
now that you could have this
quasi-steady state universe that could
expand and produce observations that
match what hubble and friends had seen
but also you could have you know
formation of the elements but you
wouldn't need to do that in stars you
could do that in some early dense phase
of the universe
but that could have been preceded by a
cycle and
and uh and i find it interesting that
we're still kind of in that mode like
sir roger penrose paul steinhardt
um and and other scientists are still
very much
thinking about cyclic universes so what
is it about these you know kind of
cosmogenes formation stories
uh that are so persistent that they
refuse to die
why are people so interested in
explanations other than a single big
bang that produced our universe
well it's the scientific method brian uh
right you
you don't want to throw away i mean you
know so
the the i think the cyclic ideas are
are powerful because um you know it's
difficult to think about a singularity
it's
difficult to think about you know
everything coming from a you know a
single
time a big bang and so in a way it at
least to me
it sort of um you know pushes the
question
of the origin of the universe a little
farther back in time
yeah i don't know i guess i it doesn't
help me that much
to um
but but it does avoid the problem of uh
you know you know something very special
happening at one time and then you know
the question is immediately what
you know what happened before that so
this at least says well
we've got a model for that but you know
what happened before that
i don't know right yeah it's like
infinite regress
um yeah it is it is uh it is
very fascinating to see how people make
uh
make you know kind of everything that's
new is old again or everything new is
old
new again or old again i don't know but
uh i want to ask you speaking of things
that are new in our
in our remaining time before i get to
the questions of the allegations that
are unsettling in the alligator
the alligator peter that alligated them
um i want to ask you
what you are working on nowadays because
i know you're you
you are ever wanting to branch out and
never stay
stagnating resting on your laureate-like
laurels so what are you up to nowadays
what is the timbi lab
buzzing with excitement about these days
well um most of what we're doing these
days is
is uh trying to
map out larger chunks of the universe
than
um than we've been able to do before
what people have been able to do before
so essentially i like to think of it as
creating
many maps of the universe at different
slices
of distance from us so imagine the
universe being like an
onion and looking at each of the the
shells and the onion
each one farther from us um and so these
shells go you know go all the way back
to uh the the microwave background
radiation itself which of course has you
know
told us um a lot about the cosmology
and will continue to do so but um
the technique that we're working on is
is to use
the radio emission from hydrogen gas
neutral
neutral hydrogen gas as a tool
to to zero in on different
epochs in the universe so
because the universe is expanding
more distant or older parts of the
universe
are appear to be receding from us at
ever higher velocities
and that is is causing the wavelengths
of light that we see
from those places to stretch out or the
frequencies that we look at them with
to be lower than when they were emitted
so we're we're trying to make maps of
the
the a particular spectral line from
hydrogen gas as a function of redshift
which
translates into a function of distance
from us
and then basically to try to capture as
much information about the structure
three-dimensional structure of the
universe as we can between where we are
now and as
close as far back in time to get as
close as we can to the
time when the microwave background was
emitted
so um yeah so it's like a super cmb
i like to think of it that way so you
can analyze each of the maps
at each of these different redshifts
and and extract more cosmic information
even than we've been able to get from
the microwave background
so it's you know it's a very challenging
experiment
it reminds me of the early days of the
cmb experiments
to you know words the signal was not the
signal size was not known it wasn't
clear whether the technique would work
and so at this point in my career i'm
you know this is something i
you know i really want to try to do uh
maybe i'm willing to take more of a risk
than a lot of people would be at this
you know who are or younger and
um so yeah so that's that's that's the
main focus of what we're up to
these days sort of a combination of
microwave background measurements but
um um sort of sort of extend
expanding that to the to the whole
universe pretty pretty ambitious
and what kind of technology is that
using
[Music]
so that is using
uh radio receivers not very different
from the you know
the basic idea that uh that dickey came
up with
um but these are um
so these are ground-based radio
telescopes uh they're
you know a few of these that people are
are putting together on the
on the planet um that work
by um so to make these things sensitive
enough to see
what turns out to be a pretty small
signal you need a lot of
um basically a lot of telescopes and so
these are um arrays
that are arranged as radio
interferometers
so that you uh which basically means
that you can combine the information
from all the independent antennas
to create maps as if they're coming from
a single large antenna
and and with the additional sensitivity
of having multiple
multiple copies of the of the of each
antenna
so um so it's actually using fairly um
you know um you know stuff is that is
directly traceable to
things from a dickey's paper on
radiometry
but now um um much more sensitive than
he was able to to
to put together because of
um you know huge technical improvements
in
in sensitivity of receivers
very good okay peter well we have
reached the end of the
regularly structured interview and now
we're going to play a game
if you are willing to do so uh and that
is i'm going to give you a rubik's cube
with uh five of the six sides have been
solved but the sixth side remains to be
solved and i want you to
solve it in real no i'm just kidding i'm
not gonna do it thank you brian
that's the only way i can i i
actually have to go to office hours oh
okay well i don't want to keep you i'm
so sorry
i thought i've kept you over i'm so
sorry all right well this means you have
to come back again
yeah happy to come back again this is a
joy and yeah thank you for uh you know
being a gracious host
and not exposing the uh the warts and so
forth the underbelly
the underbelly you can edit this in such
a way that
that that all comes out so
all right peter we love you we are
indebted to you
and i can't wait till we speak again any
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this video i hope you'll
like and subscribe
to this channel and also click here for
the video with john mather winner of the
nobel prize in physics was also deeply
influenced by david wilkinson who we
discussed in this video my phd advisors
phd advisor my grandadvisor
[Music]
you